et aujourd'hui on va jouer un jeu vidéo
fait par quelqu'un qui en école de game
design ça présage que du bon il a mis
quatre mois à développer jeu c'est fait
avec le moteur source donc le moteur de
counter strike source d'où le nom source
et il a joué un jeu un petit synopsis
facile c'est que j'ai du mal à chaque
fois et à introduire les jeux il m'a
aidé merci beaucoup
tu te réveilles attaché à une chaise
dans un labo ils veulent fouilles et ont
passé est ta mémoire mais il te croit
mort en restant en vie tu vas pouvoir
repartir dans le passé comprendre
pourquoi tu es là aidé par un inconnu tu
devras retrouver jumbo et éviter de
refaire les mêmes erreurs des endroits
te sembleront familiers des clins d'oeil
à toutes ces années de vidéo ainsi qu'à
des youtuber il manque là ya pas la fin
de la phrase c'est pas grave merci pour
ce petit nos petits c'est parti
trop fier fait c'est trop collec faut
faire le sale travail accompli sur la
capture et tue tous les jours à venir
des mecs à puisieux pour fermer taillieu
lucas dépêche
e
[Musique]
la digue a géré toit dans le passé du
coup oh merde
or le battre ça va sur moi ça sera temps
d'aller sur moi
ah et oui j'étais pas bon ok direction
le pass est atteint c'est trop cool
ils ont même fait le doublage des
personnages et où c'est un super cadeau
noël que moi j'ai fait là je suis hyper
heureux
aucun travail tu savais
ouah ouah de fuck ses matches comme ça
toi c'est pas moi je suis comme ça moi
je suis enfin c'est comme ça c'est la
bromance pour garda a bougé un cadre
avec une photo de mon avis cas comme ça
dans ma chance
imprimés ont d'énormes dégâts je t'aime
bien mais ouais t'es où t'es où t'es où
vas tu
ok ok ok ok je prends le temps qu eva si
tu aimes guidée avec je t'écoute
totalement on serait dans die hard c'est
ouf c'est parti mais tu me connais ok
web
au delà mais bien sûr beaucoup mon sort
de la tuffière que dans ça marchait pas
je devrai donner tout de suite aux oies
diouf mais que ce passe comme ça chez
moi en rien moi c'est je fais un seul
gros tas voilà ok je vous la porte ta je
suis sous pression mon gars c'est ce
qu'ils allaient qui montrent très bien
et ça ressemble à mon m haies mais
qu'ils sont basés pour de vrai sur là où
j'habitais avant dans la maison où
j'habitais avant c'était comme ça sauf
que c'était les portais un peu plus
lointain c'est trop bon ça c'était la
porte des toilettes mais attends mec
c'est exactement comme chez moi comme
les geeks ou saas et les toilettes ces
mecs c'est exactement ça et la droite
avance à mon bureau et ça c'est
exactement [ __ ] les gars vous
franchement à ça me touche je suis ému
franchement à l'eau continue bref là on
en parle de crise
ah c'est bien là où il ya le frigo
[ __ ] mais c'est incroyable non sans
déconner c'est ouf voilà faut que
j'aille ouvre le frigo et je me fasse un
petit un petit stack posait mais même ce
tas coup c'était souvent dans mon frigo
jeu grosse blague grosse blague n'aura
pas les connaît non plus ok alors du
coup faut que je me fasse quoi assagi ça
je l'avais pas j'aurais bien aimé mais
j'avoue j'avais pas ça il ya des nous il
est bon tout ce qu'on aime de la pizza
avec jalloud est tu critique pas mon
chez moi [ __ ] qu'est ce que tu as fait
un malin plaisir à le modéliser bain en
plus mauvais choix j'ai jamais fait des
fêtes comme ça chez moi pour de vrai
voilà petite confession yad'abord
prochain médias - il va être dessus ma
mission ça voudrait dire un mot alors
qu'il est atteint c'est hyper fidèles
même ses étagères l'arbre à chat ça me
fait super bizarre en fait de voir
vraiment mon chez-moi hyper enfin
reproduit manière hyper fidèle donc mais
dans un jeu coadou attend le gars il est
amoureux de ces avis quoi il s'endort en
pensant que chaque soir il aimait dans
des cadres et tout c'est terrible alors
john beauté ou mec parce que je trouve
des mots clés mort bien là bon j'ai
goûté ou des canapés non oui ce qui a
trait aux [ __ ] whiskas chez jumbo il
est là je les trouvais mais il est sur
un cadre c'est ça
alain jusqu'à c'est le cadre reste au
mur plus tard pas mal de cadres ya le
lait il est pas en train de percer les
bouteilles de lait non c'est bon dans la
poubelle non [ __ ] c'est le bordel mon
gars et dans mon bureau à et j'aurais
mis ou la clé où elle met la clé mon
gars tu as je ne sais rien de ça pour un
peu déblayé tout ça là où est la clé
vous êtes dans la porte d'en face à bah
voilà
cette pièce rarement vexer les pièces
sont pas exemptes dette rouge et en
linge quoi et là c'est devenu une pièce
toute belle voilà du mec qui voue un
culte pour cyprien dans les chiottes à
dans les chiottes les portraits de
cyprien bon tout cas pas la clé dans les
chiottes c'est les bestioles vraiment
très très belle mais y'a vraiment pas la
clé est dans ma chambre je pense qu'il
est dans la chambre à clé je pense que
je les ratés mais elles doivent vers la
l2 dans tout ce bordel [ __ ] mais
pourquoi j'ai pas envie à la chambre de
mon jeune âge arrange toujours en plus
c'est faux ou à la clé contrairement à
moi je ne passe avec la voie de la clé
s'il te plaît aux mails et la [ __ ] mon
gars j'ai mis tellement de temps à
trouver cette [ __ ] de clé du bon alors
oh là là haut tu as un mec ses fidèles
de ouf ça abusé la chasse ok d'accord il
m'a dit qu'il y avait un passage vers
les deux cartons qui à la base ça ouais
c'est quoi ça pourquoi des fois ils
commencent à souffrir des fois il
souffre plus d'accord faut mettre du
poids là dessus ah c'est ça ok faut
juste mettre du poids là dessus et ce
avec jumbo vu qu'il fait 200 kg il a pu
l'ouvrir fassi fihri qu'est ce que je
peux mettre de lure un écran dessus ah
ben on est bon l'esg au piano c'est vrai
mais c'est mon chat attendait que c'est
ton chat s il ya un monstre les gars je
vous tue je vous tue oh [ __ ] c'est bon
bouteilles des oeufs qui ya quoi en bail
à jumbo jumbo contaminait derrière ces
superbes à la bouteille tout les murs
ok on se retrouve en bas jumbo celtique
au genou il s'est barré mais attends moi
jumbo je vous dis entier qui avait par
bones coeur sous ma maison ça n'est même
pas secure access à y a un truc à
brancher quelque chose du genre je
suppose c'est la basse et de l'autre
côté fo et j'accède à ce bouton a
peut-être que je lance un truc de suba
genre ça je pensais ça astrologique
attend ça peut-être je peux aller ouvre
toi j'ai peur je crois vraiment influé
les gars
ah ça fait beaucoup de bruit ça allait
on dégage on dégage monga jumbo il est
parti je sais plus où au [ __ ] je vais
mourir
attention ça je peux pas passer puisque
le poiré home et le power il est relié
là bas c'est bon il s'est arrêté aux
caisses allaient arrêter on pourra y
aller
ok y'a un mec en face six länder
what the fuck les gars c'est pas gentil
c'est trash orthez du tout de perdre
pourquoi jumbo [ __ ] ça y est on part
dans un délire mogari lucho m'bow moi je
veux jumbo mois à temps il va me courir
après j'ai peur je me casse a un dans le
doute je perds pas de temps mon gars je
me tiens dit moitié ouverts banon banon
s'est pas ouvert pourquoi ce sera
ouverte ce serait trop facile là ouais
ouais ouais là j'arrive dans là bas une
copie je peux la mettre
ok c'est bon oh [ __ ] aide pour allumer
la lampe torche salut mais les gars job
on arrive dans un truc de gestion moi je
touche à tout un jab sur eux surtout qui
passa à l'eau aux [ __ ] tout à péter
tout à fait t'es ok ben on y va j'ai
compris ok d'accord ça s'effondre sur
moi je peux y aller c'est un zombie à et
en plus je brûle à comment je fais il va
tomber avant il a tombé avant mais oui
il va tomber si bas [ __ ] j'avais lu
tout ça m'a soulagé de voir tomber
secours allez on se casse çà parcours du
combattant regarde et diogo il a fait
tout ça au calme et ou de mort oh il est
vivant lui on cuit et [ __ ] je savais
je suis choquée board en août dans doute
voilà je te jeter des gommes ok j'ai
activé la norme du coup les portes se
réouvre allez on y va
ok faut que je casse les trucs hp casser
les ports d'accord je n'avais pas d'armé
en fait je pense le but c'est que
j'aille là-bas mais le blème c'est que
la porte ne s'ouvre pas bah les amis je
sèche complètement sur cette partie là
du niveau dont je propose qu'on appelle
le créateur du jeu ça fait drôle ça
j'espère que la réponse sinon on va être
bloquée longtemps allô allô benjamin
ouais c'est squeeze au il me reconnaît
comment tu vas ça donne avec ben écoute
très bien les gens te disent bonjour je
suis actuellement en train de tourner
vidéo sur ton jeu et je suis bloqué je
suis bloqué au moment où il ya un zombie
coupée en deux entre deux portes et
qu'il faut débloquer la porte à l'autre
bout du couloir
c'est vrai ouais ouais absolument mais
c'est faux mais de la fumée c'était quoi
l'offre ainsi le ventilo amnésique
un court circuit un court-circuit
affaire ouais c'est ça ouais bon je me
démerde avec cette info et si j'y arrive
pas je te rappelle aux gays cette option
sur tous les jeux quand je suis bloqué
trois gardiens j'appelle les mecs qui
auraient développé oui j'ai emblème
c'est un mix de crise est ici bien que
cette heure de jeu ça ne veut pas nous
balancer le le truc voilà à temps on va
lancer sa dessus ok ça a cassé et il ya
3 6 dans l'ordre qu'il faut je pense
qu'il ya un an d'affaires je veux dire
que j'ai appris à parler et 2,2 et 2,3
oh eh ben voilà bah je crois j'ai eu de
la chance ça a marché mais qu à nantes
en temps je me suis peut-être un peu
l'âme est faux je les tue c'est bon ok
ok plus que des tubes ça j'ai eu peur
ces salles énigmes ice et se bastonner
commençait bien le faire marion reste de
la vie le dernier coup un slot mots et
on passe
est-ce qu'on va rejoindre jumbo alors
faisons régime qui va tous les mecs je
suis attentif à ce qu'on a ajouté croire
anna j'en étais bien dans le passé c'est
bel et bien la fin on avait peu plus
largement grave ou pas j'avais un mec
c'était énorme [ __ ] c'était tellement
cool je suis super content merci d'avoir
pris tant de faire ça à quatre mois
j'espère que tu n'as pas rater tes
études pour autant parce que tu as dû
passer mon couteau et j'espère que ça
t'a pas pris du temps sur le temps que
tu consacres un des devoirs et bat
n'hésitez pas à mêler de ça vous a plu
moi je suis tout ému 1000mercis c'était
génial peut-être y aura un chapitre 2
dans quatre ou six mois du coup et bah
j'ai hâte mon gars allaient rester
regarder la vidéo sur celui des
prochaines sur tout le monde
[Musique]